- So the question is
can Twitter actually ban
the President of the United
States from its platform
and a whole bunch of the
president's supporters?
Well, do you think that
you could ban someone
from making a speech inside
of your home because that's
kind of the same issue.
Twitter is a private company
and the First Amendment doesn't
prohibit private companies
or individuals from controlling
their own private property.
Frankly, if the government could control
what a company like Twitter says,
that probably itself would be a violation
of the First Amendment.
So what Twitter has done in
banning a whole bunch of people
doesn't violate the First Amendment
and it doesn't violate the
Communications Decency Act,
section 230.
In fact CDA 230 has nothing to do
with this whatsoever.
But anyway,
stay tuned for more election coverage
and I'll see you in court.